florida lieutenant governor jeanette
nunez joins me now lieutenant governor
thank you very much for being with us
tell me what you're hoping to target in
this legislation and and how concerned
you are about what's happening to
children at the hands of these cartels
across this open border
indeed martha what we've seen with the
supreme court granting the governor's
request and panel a statewide grand jury
is we're going to be able to take the
next step investigating the criminal
enterprises that are that are taking
hold in child trafficking human
smuggling drug smuggling all the things
that are impacting not just a border
state like texas but states like florida
and so governor desantis has been very
clear we are going to do everything we
can to keep floridians safe and that
includes using the tools that we have at
our disposal the governor has
created a strike force
to interdict human smuggling that is
taking place in florida he's got the
grand jury that will be investigating
and looking at what are the things that
we can do to protect floridians and he's
also made it illegal for common carriers
to knowingly work with enterprises that
are bringing illegals into florida
biden's border disaster has made
everyone less safe with historic numbers
record numbers of individuals flowing
through our border enough fentanyl to
wipe out the entire population of the
united states this is a crisis it's a
humanitarian crisis it's a national
security crisis and for governor
desantis and i we're going to continue
to do everything we can to keep
floridians safe so how do you handle the
cartel part of this story when you're
paneling a grand jury in florida
dealing with investigations i would
assume into
americans
yes and what we're doing not only
working with a grand jury obviously they
will investigate and they will have all
the tools at their disposal to see those
criminal trafficking enterprises because
let's be clear this is not just
well-intentioned people trying to get
folks across the border these are
criminal cartels they have an illicit
industry that is far surpassing the arms
industry and will likely surpass the
drug industry human smuggling they do
not treat those individuals as we've
seen by some of the
issues that you brought up in your
segment we have what we're seeing is
that these individuals uh have little
regard for the safety and well-being and
they are using them as commodities so in
the grand jury as well of all the other
pieces that we discussed we're going to
continue to look at ways to not only
interdict the human trafficking that's
taking place but also make sure that we
prosecute them to the fullest extent of
the law
jeanette thank you jeanette nunez
lieutenant governor of florida under
governor desantis very good to have you
with us hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else